hey kids real quick by show of hands how
many of you have had disagreements with
fellow classmates in your life
so a part of life right even though you
might be friendly with somebody in here
you might not see eye to eye on
everything and that's okay well you have
to remember is you can't just focus on
how you feel about it you have to
remember there's another person too and
you might want to start thinking about
why are they thinking that why do they
see it differently when I was a kid and
somebody would pick on me or not be nice
for some reason whether it was good
Parenting by my mom or because it was my
the way I was born or probably a
combination of both I would always think
they weren't being mean to me they were
in a bad place and they were unhappy and
something must have been going on in
their life and so they're hurt and so
maybe that's showing up with them not
being nice the way I solve problems is
through compassion and through empathy
and trying to understand what the other
person's problem is and how we solve it